next um has your ex ever shown up in
your dreams uninvited
well the new york times reports that
experts say that just because they pop
up into your dreams does not mean that
you secretly want them back there could
be a million reasons for the cameo the
key is to analyze the dream and in the
here and now
from your current emotional state they
give an example one man was thinking of
reaching out to an ex-spouse but then in
his dream she appeared at his house and
then
he hid from her in the kitchen and when
he woke up he was like oh then i must
want to hide from her in life i'm not
ready i'm not going to reach out
um ross have you had any of your exes
come visit your dreams you're about to
get married yeah they better not they
better not show up no uh no but i don't
take a lot of i don't put a lot of stock
in dreams like this you know i mean like
the other night i had a dream that i was
camel and i could tell you i had a hump
and everything i can tell you right now
with certain i do not want to be a camel
all right
and so just because you dream of an ex
is not mean you want to be with your ex
dreams are like you know there's like an
encyclopedia a rolodex of things you see
in your life and dreams are like at
rando they just pop up so i've seen a
few exes in my nightmares oh hey
yeah
have you ever had a dream of an ex that
made you go
um i i think that's the only place i'm
getting action these days ross is in my
dreams and every once like every six
months i'll have the hottest dream and
i'll be like oh my god really yes
and i'm like oh i am the goodness and
alive with the hold on so what does that
word mean what was the bitterness like i
have a libido like i'm like i'm alive i
have a pulse
what business women now
i just love that in your dreams one of
your exes was all up in your labourness
[Applause]
you know
dreams they're a safe space to work a
lot of things out as you said oh god
your little mind is fascinating isn't it
it's fun to peel you like an onion all
right but next up here's a question
about oh anyone here in a group text you
know what i mean like one of those
chants with a bunch of people a billion
yeah well there's the the etiquette is
just very blurry but this is advice from
the column at the washington post a
person wrote in to say that after their
husband got covered even though
themselves had tested negative they they
offered to skip an upcoming outdoor
hangout with friends all right and then
the other friends all agreed that that
would be best so that person just sat it
out but the friends they went on the
excursion and they left them on the
group chat and then that person felt
super left out and it hurt them to read
all those excited messages about the
event that they were no longer a part of
so
girl you're on my nerves now i
i just feel like i don't want anyone to
feel left out but like
remove yourself from the text is it that
right
i actually asked about that and i was
like wait can't she just get off the
chain yeah can you mute it or get yours
you can remove yourself i i don't i
can't find any circumstance of which you
cannot remove yourself from a text chain
she said she tried but couldn't i i i um
raise of hands how many people think
this woman should have even if she
couldn't get herself off the chain just
stop looking yeah
uh-huh yeah uh-huh
i know i know i know do we feel do we
sound like heartless to her because she
probably had she thought her feelings
were hurt but your hurt feelings are
becoming my full-time job
[Music]
you